this is a paper panic saga level 63
walkthrough tutorial I'm going to play the level
and beat it
explain how are you read it it's a
tricky local
are knowing 12 moon and
from are your stats user over here
so in order to get too near to clear out
the ice
and a lot of times you're on the
moves before you can get all the way
or there is one paper that
by the statues
you have to exploded or beginning
edge and we're going to try to do that
but at the same time we're going to open
up this area because that's how we can
treat truckers
which is a pretty bad layout
Gary no
no big matches start with film school
rearrange things
Prosser show
CC that's what we're trying to do is
return explodes in papers here with some
weight but also from
this
well shockwaves have a double nearly
they grow peppers broccoli also
historical
all right now we have a lot of the ice
clear will try to either
damage this warm enough to get more
purposes Paul
the earth that's where we were
no now whenever the
a prepared starts and purposely clear
new
boys
we still have some purple trapped in the
summer probably gonna make it through to
you
you can see it starts out really
confined here
things open up pretty quickly or realize
so
taxes on to hit so there's really not
much chance that we can
take them we don't have a shot here
forms going to go ahead with for the
purple on
I'll see better for
roll of film wild things are
them isn't too bad about this one is it
actually is
plays pretty quick so even that's what
it's really frustrating at times
you know the labor from doing the same
thing I miss
taking trying to grow peppers across as
possible
clearly a cyndaquil many shots here yet
a choice here we are to me or vertical
horizontal forgettable
amigo the teasers the brutal inside here
we don't have any
damage
alright so you wanna hit these thirties
and the pauper world
we only shots though
we need to clear X formally lol we don't
have a way to do it
yet so from a good takers double
shockwave here
it's a start
actual
and no even see it even though he
exploded this
purple are those who when it wasn't
right here really did help us out
a time because now there's no more
papers though
until we can hit were the stuff that's
who were or group
still have goals that group called well
and they ran away with making software
them
much are you them
and
we have a we have five years or so it's
not lost
at this point we're gonna have hip
YouTube outlook in this case cater
or so
let's look at our options we have
nothing reappear
nothing great here we had
vertical on the weekend we can try to
set up
well
worth now we have
who know the here who
we aren't going toward blum blum on the
go ahead and make this
this fall here the first because you
know you have removed this is gonna
was gonna potentially it's gonna explode
a purple
its gonna explode yellow it's been a
potentially to clear up this whole space
for moving
there was room
fantastico
we go
you who make this bull here this
the start a chain reaction Ruth
appears so now we have a similar
situation
we get the process a couple different
ways
we could try to explore the purple
sensors and order the closest to it now
when we do instead the
them explore group that's going to
remove this wonderful bottom
we could you know little the concert
preparing
may get another brutal because statues
so you know it's not perfect it's
the best
see a boon job pre-order so reason you
can do that here there's only three
colors
there's a pretty good chance that
mcaleese gonna call
to the time
needed it's a on it's a frustrating
level or tries at all
you'll get close and I get it or you
won't get anywhere
you can clear out the ice from the
beginning revolted from our guide in
take your time at the end to pick the
best matches work you'll be able to get
past it
420 hope this helps thanks